I was playing black here against strong
feed a master William Duckworth this
game it gets really sharp and tactically
interesting so might take us a while to
go through all the variations but
hopefully it'll be really cool and
instructive and everyone's tactical
level will improve a bit I played this
last year in October and round-robin
tournament in Los Angeles so my opponent
play d4 I play d6 sort of tempting him
to go into an e4 perk defense and that's
what he did it's a night of six nights
III c6 geom Akopian who you guys
probably know he's given lectures here
before he he showed me this system when
I was his student and he likes this line
very well and it's very interesting it's
basically a perk but black plays this
move c6 pretty early and they don't
always feel and keto their Bishop on g7
so we'll eventually transpose into kind
of like even a Philidor position after
black plays a 5 so it's an interesting
line especially when you want to kind of
get a complicated game with black Bishop
III 97 Queen d2 e 592 so my opponent is
playing as if I was playing like the
classical perk like like g6 so very
popular line here's the play Bishop e3
Bishop g7 Queen d2 and then played like
f3 and h4 h5 Bishop h6 and attack on the
Kings side
so I'm guessing that was his idea
against the system I chose but it's not
quite as effective here for white
because I haven't played g6 and Bishop
g7 so there's no there's no target yet
on my king side for y to really attack
but he played 92 and his idea is to play
93 and maybe Knight f5 and as we saw
earlier obviously this is a pretty
dangerous plan sometimes right so Bishop
e7 f3 I Castle
d5 so d5 is very interesting move
basically why is trying to close the
center so that he can attack on the
Kings side so I think a mistake here
would be to play c5 because then there's
no tension in the center the position is
closed and White has pretty much free
rein to attack on the Kings side so they
can play like g4 and 93 Knight f5 and
black doesn't have any counter play yet
so Y can proceed this way so that's why
I decided just to play Knight b6 so that
I'm always threatening to maybe take on
d5 and try to open up the center so it's
not so it's much riskier for white to
start pushing there King side pawns so B
3 I was threatening Knight c4 and
another move could have been Knight g3
to protect the score with their Bishop
but you know why it would love to put
their 9 on g3 after G to g4 so this
would be kind of awkward here in the
knight is blocking the Jeep on so my
opponent played b3 but this weakens the
dark squares especially the knight on c3
a little bit but right now it's not so
clear that block can really take
advantage of this so b3 is a very
sensible move rook e8
yeah yeah I definitely thought about
this move and I did it a few moves later
but I guess I just wasn't sure if I
wanted to do it just yet I guess I
thought I can always make this exchange
and I wanted to see how white develops
their pieces first sometimes it's
beneficial for black to just develop
like Bishop d7 and rook c8 and only then
capture and also I was thinking maybe
he'll take on c6 which would be
beneficial for me so I figured Ricky
eight maybe just a flexible useful move
here and actually the point of this move
is very interesting I was thinking white
might want to play a four at some point
to attack my knight on on b6 and against
this move I was thinking about
sacrificing a pawn with E 4 so after
white takes Knight G for a Bishop f4 and
Bishop f6 I thought black is getting
good compensation here because I'm
getting this a 5 score for my knight and
the bishop is really strong and is
diagonal and I thought my rook is of
course well placed on the e-file so that
was one idea behind rook e8 to
potentially sacrifice this pawn so I
think for this reason my opponent played
h3 which is kind of impressive that he
found my idea and now of course he's
controlling the g4 square so here I
eventually took on d5 and I played
Bishop f5 this is a really provocative
move because basically what what do you
guys think white is gonna do next after
move
like Bishop f5 yeah
g4 I mean this move is just asking what
to play g4 cuz you know they wanted to
play it all ready to attack on a king
side in here I'm letting him play g4
with a tempo but I figured that you know
my bishop would be really strong on g6
on this diagonal and that there's not so
much danger to my King yet because white
doesn't really have a target so far
there's no pawn on g6 that I can attack
with like h4 h5 open the H file so I
figured you know I should be able to
create counter play in the center so my
opponent played h4 this is the
definitely the most natural move
threatening h5 and here black has a few
options here so my first thing to think
was h5 myself to try and lock up the
king side and if I takes I can take with
my knight and h4 is hanging and seems
like White's position is really weak
upon an h4 is weak opponent now f3 is
weak and box position looks really good
like the pieces all have good squares
and are playing but I think I didn't
like if white just plays g5 and I have
to retreat my knight if I play 97 maybe
now a4 is annoying and a5 comes and I
don't know I feel like black is getting
a really passive position here and why
it's gonna Castle queenside and play f4
and it looks like they're getting pretty
interesting attack here but it's
probably it might be okay for black h6
was another option but you know g5 and
takes takes Knight h7 and rook to you on
just defending the pawn and again like
my knight and h7 is out of the game and
next why it's going to Castle queenside
and play f4 and try to
HAC and I mean these officials are very
sharp so that's definitely playable for
black but I was looking for a way to
just try to get immediate counter play
so that maybe I could seize the
initiative and try to try to win a very
sharp game so I came up with this move
rook c8 it's just kind of it's kind of a
crazy idea but after h5 what do you
think blacks next move is
that looks very interesting but should
take situ is is the idea yeah let me
quickly show you guys so the point here
is that if Queen takes situ I take the
central pawn and and black is getting a
lot of play well we'll go back to this
line I want to look at Knight takes d5
real quick because that's kind of
interesting so your idea is if Knight
takes d5 rook takes you to right yeah it
probably doesn't work out because Y can
take another piece or the check and then
maybe like Queen D one and the bishop
still trap so I don't think block really
gets enough for their the sacrifice
material but yeah the point of rook c8
is diploid Bishop takes c2 luring the
Queen to c2 and then they takes d5 with
a lot of pressure on the C file so I
figure white will play Bishop d2
defending the knight getting the bishop
out of the attack and now like efore is
really strong and this is an idea that's
gonna keep popping up in this game is
that once bikeways efore basically
whites position starts falling apart the
point is if white takes I take with the
night and you know Bishop h4 check is a
threat I'm also threatening to take
everything on c3 and whites King on e1
is of course very uncomfortable and if
you know like f4 and black always has
like III or Knight takes g4 and then an
important line is like if white castles
Queen side night before
and 93 check and 95 and basically white
skink is animating that night before as
a threat and white whites in serious
trouble of course
so well it's really funny about this
position is that uh white doesn't have
to take this bishop like it's still
trapped so when I was calculating back
here before Rick c8 I saw these lines
with Queen takes you to Knight takes d5
I got really excited then I saw rook c8
h5 i should take c2 rook c1 and i got
really depressed looks like I'm just
losing the piece anyways and white Sura
comes to c2 defends the knight on c3 I
don't win the d5 pawn looks like I'm I'm
just losing a piece here but then I
I started thinking further I was in a
really like a fighting mood so I wanted
to try and make it work and I came up
with this idea to apply e4 and after
this move white White's in serious
trouble because their King is stuck in
the center and a lot of their pieces are
under fire here so rook takes c2 I just
take this pawn on f3 I'm threatening to
win my piece back and then g4 is also
hanging and then once the knight moves
Knight takes G for my rook on EI is
lined up against White's King and this
is really devastating Bishop if the
bishop moves anywhere I'm going to have
like a terrible discover check and let's
say King d1 I take on the e3 Bishop g5
and rookie three for example and I'm
gonna win the piece back on c3 and once
black wins their piece back you know
they're gonna be up a couple of ponds
and whites King is going to be really
exposed so of course that'll be winning
for me
so once I saw this idea with efore I
realized that you know the sacrifice is
probably going to work of course it also
comes with the idea to just play Bishop
d3 and save my piece and white is
basically just an in dire straits here
another possible move for why it would
have been g5 counter attacking the
knight and this is often the kind of
move you might miss in your calculations
because you you generally only look for
your own tactical resources and you
don't look for ways for your opponent to
counter-attack but of course you should
because sometimes your opponent might
have some really strong tactical
resource that you shouldn't miss here
after g5 I think I can just take on f3
and white takes on f6 and then I just
calmly recapture it with the bishop and
the night on e2 is hanging and the
knight on c3 is hanging so White's
Knight can't move because the Bishop
takes c3 well you have to get too near
the line because you know block is down
a couple of pieces rook takes c2 takes
takes and here from far away I was able
to see a nice tactic here so maybe you
guys can find it the hint is that you
know blocks rooks are pretty perfectly
placed and it should be enough for a
combination
so Rick takes III cool Queen takes III
yeah that's probably good that takes d5
and it's night X well maybe this is
risky is they can take on f6
no Queen takes do you have Queen e8 mate
gf well I have a lot of pawns for the
piece but but now my king is open so I
don't know this could be really unclear
maybe White's even winning here but I
think you can just play you can probably
just play rook takes c3 and Knight takes
d5 and once I take on c3 I'm gonna have
a knight and three pawns for the rook
which is definitely enough material and
whites King you know will be very weak
and exposed blacks King will be safe and
I'll have this some really strong dark
sword bishop
so this position is is definitely
winning for black but other than rook
takes c3 also or Rick takes c3 probably
also works but Bishop takes c3 and maybe
the simplest and Knight takes d5 and the
Queen moves and Bach is just up three
pawns
so yeah I was really happy when I found
this idea which is Bishop takes f6 and
suddenly why can't you know defend any
of their pieces so at this point even
though I obviously couldn't calculate
everything out because white does have
some options on almost every move
intuitively I felt like black should
have enough for their sacrifice because
there's all these tactics and tricks
that are working out in my favor and
because White's Bishop on e3 and they're
9 and C 3 they end up hanging so many
lines that it's very likely that black
should have enough play 4 for the piece
so in the game my opponent actually
played g5 immediately which I also
considered so I played um well what did
I play here efore yeah exactly this is
just the key tactical idea to open up
the e-file and get my rook and Bishop
into play now that's exactly right yeah
what I was thinking here is that you
know White's King isn't yet Castle and
you know their pieces are developed but
it you know I felt like there was some
kind of vulnerability to them also after
Rick's c8 I was thinking you know if Y
doesn't play h5 well then a this is a
useful move of course so you know if y
doesn't play h5 then I don't see how
they're going to make progress and also
the idea of putting the rook on c8 is
that if whites Knight ever goes to g3
I'm just going to sacrifice the exchange
here and when the central pawn
and probably take the you know dark
short bishop in a position like this you
know I mean there's some concrete lines
here of course like the c2 pawn is
hanging and maybe I can play d5 an
attack but just to think about it just
think about the position it's like
blacks black should always have enough
compensation here because the dark
squared Bishop is potentially very
strong White's King doesn't have a safe
Square and you know for the exchange I
have two central pawns so it's like
intuitively it seems like it should be a
good sacrifice for black so once I saw
some of these lines I figured that you
know as well as whites King being the
center that there should be some kind of
tactical potential here for me
so h5 that should take C to g5 and E for
now if my opponent takes on f6 I'm just
going to recapture and F takes e4 I have
this nice move Bishop takes e4 and I'm
threatening White's rook on g1 and if
Knight takes e4 I can think about taking
the rook on a1 but I can also just take
on e4 and let's say rook c1 try drugs
and take this pawn so basically black
has two pawns for the sacrificed piece
but white King is going to be in the
center for the rest of the game my
bishop on f6 is a very strong piece my
rooks are really active and the most
important thing here that really um is
going for black is that white just
doesn't have any threats against my king
my king is perfectly safe and
psychologically it's very hard to play a
position without being able to create a
threat
white just has to try and organize some
kind of defense and you know blacks
ideas to play like
nice Evan you know put pieces on the
e-file try to bother the whites King and
you know any move here I think the d5
pawn is also hanging concretely and the
worst thing that can happen here for
black is why it's able to consolidate
and defend and maybe even trade Queens
you know if they're lucky but I feel
like even in the endgame this wouldn't
be so easy for a white to win because
the pawn on d5 is probably weak and lost
upon an h5 as weak so in the end game
with five three pawns for the piece it's
like black is hardly worse so once I
realized that at worst I'm like gonna
have two pawns for the piece then
definitely the sacrifice is worth it
because the first thing is that your
opponent is probably not going to play
the best defense it's very hard to find
and even if they do you're not losing so
it's definitely a risk worth taking
I think so any questions so far I know
it's a lot to cover after just like 14
15 moves okay cool
so my opponent here played a really good
defensive move if you guys could find it
that would be great but basically he's
trying to keep the position from blowing
up and he's trying to keep his King safe
yeah brilliant
f4 that's what he played and it's a very
good move because well strategically
because it keeps the e-file closed and
for now White's King is in in the center
but at least the e-files not open so
it's somewhat safe and also white you
know is still attacking this Bishop and
is still attacking the knight so I was
you know before I played rook c8 I did
see this position and I saw I would have
94 and this is pretty much where I
stopped I figured you can't take on c2
because I
take on III and my knight can retreat
the safety to f5 if needed and the other
line I saw was that if Bishop takes b6
very natural move seeing as how both
bishops were hanging I would have Queen
takes b6 Queen takes you to Queen F to
check now if King d1 I have 93 check so
King d2 and at the very least I actually
have a perpetual check here again f king
do you one night have to chuck when is
the rook so I saw that if my opponent
plays all these moves I can force it
draw and I figured this wasn't too bad
because it requires my opponent to find
a lot of good defensive moves and then
if we end up drawing anyways well then
you know so be it
like I played a sacrifice that gave me
tons of winning chances tons of ways y
can go wrong and if their best is to
force a draw then that's that's totally
fine like because I have so many many
chances and with black you know it's
perfectly acceptable but then on his
move I was kind of thinking I was kind
of thinking looking for ways I could
continue the game because I'm down the
piece but you know White's King is
obviously in a lot of trouble and I
found this move Bishop d8 right here
which is a really amazing move because
the bishop is just coming to one of
these diagonals be six or a five and and
and whites king is in huge trouble here
so something like rook h3 I was thinking
to attack my queen I give check and III
check and the reason this works now is
because whites rook left h1 so now the
King can't go to the c1 or d1 because
the bishop on f1 is hanging so earlier
in this position here if I tried that
oops
well you could just play king c1 and it
looks like their king is escaping to
safety and black is is down a piece I
mean there's some compensation but looks
like White's king is getting pretty safe
but here I was thinking bishop d8 and I
didn't find like a good move here for a
white because you know both Knights are
pinned the bishop doesn't have any moves
and the King can't castle so I was
thinking what h3 is the most natural
move to kick my queen but now since the
King has to come to d3 I figured Black
has some some checkmates here so I found
95 check and that sure takes Queen of 5
check wins whites Queen which is a
really nice mate also there's another
mate here if I can remember correctly
King G 4 I think I think Knight c4 check
and if the King keeps moving this way
rookie five check it's a pawns pinned
here and then Rick takes g5 I didn't he
was during the game but I found it
afterwards I was really beautiful I
assumed that would have mate during the
game so I didn't feel like looking any
further probably this is good enough I
can't imagine it's not so yeah just some
cool lines I found but I was really
proud of finding this move Bishop d8
because it is just crushing like the
bishop just comes to a5 and there's too
much pressure on White's position and
there's nothing they can really do to
defend so instead of taking on b6 my
opponent played this move Bishop h3
which I actually missed this move
originally when I applied rook c8 which
Tommy hopefully you can forgive me
because you know white spawns are on g4
and f3 so I was like I didn't it didn't
cross my mind that you know my knight is
gonna be on F on g4 and getting pinned
on the light scores but bishop if she
was played and here I guess I assumed
that once I take on e3 I should have a
really good attack here because I've got
another white stark scored bishop you
know that's their best piece and if I
can trade it off for her Knight and my
direction Bishop becomes much stronger
and I should be able to get a lot of a
lot of counter play but here it's
concrete and I mean I'm kind of
fortunate that that black has enough
resources to uh to keep the attack going
so if Queen takes III you know my bishop
on c2 is safe and I can I can move my
rook maybe rook c5 and I think I think
blacks even up
on here and the bishop is saved you know
through the d3 square so that of course
would be perfectly fine so the critical
continuation is to take on c8 so now I
play Knight G to check but even if I
played well actually ninety-two check is
okay King F 1 if King F 2 I have III
check winning the Queen
so King F 1 and Queen take CA it was my
original thought King takes G - I give
check and rook c8 or Bishop d3 is also
okay and basically block is down in
exchange here but you know White's King
is kind of weak and my bishop on d3 is
is a pretty good piece and I take c4 is
I'm sorry impossible because a bishop
takes e4 and then g3 knight is pinned so
I think micah is really good
compensation here for the exchange the
next second play like rook c8 and here I
was thinking I can even play rook c8
immediately with the idea that if Y
takes the bishop I have this Knight
takes d5 again and then I'm threatening
the night which can't really be defended
and Knight III check and I takes it a
for check so this would have been good
but of course white doesn't have to take
the bishop here so I think again black
just has good compensation for the
exchange because you know White's King
is in trouble boxing is still really
safe but I was looking for more during
the game because I was really you know I
calculated so so much already I was just
trying to look for a way to to
completely destroy White's position here
so I found Knight takes f4 which is a
really cool sacrifice I guess what was
bothering me about this line is that
you know my bishop on e7 is kind of
stuck because the pawn on d6 pawn to g5
and my ricany 8 is also stuck for the
moment so I thought if I play Knight
takes f4 with the idea Bishop takes g5
I'm I'm getting all my pieces out and
even though I'm sacrificing even more
material it's basically it's a very
principle sacrifice because I'm getting
all my pieces active and I'm breaking up
on whites King even further so the main
idea of this is that if like Knight
takes F for this trip takes g5 and I
have a lot of threats in this position
right now I'm down a rook but everything
is hanging so we can't stop our analysis
here Queen takes C to a queen takes c8
and so now this Knight is hanging and if
the knight moves
I have Knight takes d5 and this theme
comes into play over and over how the
the pin on the C file allows me to take
this D pawn and blacks down a rook here
but they have a lot of threats and those
threats are really hard to meet so 93
check is a threat and Bishop f6 is a
threat just winning a piece because of
the night is can hardly be defended and
this position right now black is down a
rook but if I can win back a piece I'll
be down in exchange but I have four
pawns now so a knight and four pawns
against the rook is definitely winning
and that's pretty much what prompted me
to go for the sacrifice I figured I can
at least win back a piece probably on c3
in most of these lines and if I get a
position when I'm you know only down in
exchange but I have four pawns and
whites King is so weak then then that
should be a winning sacrifice
so after Knight takes f4 there are other
Alliance here but my opponent played
Bishop g4 saving his light squared
bishop I think it's a good decision
because he wants to keep his light
square Bishop on the board try to defend
his King
I play Bishop takes g5 Queen take C 2 so
again black is down to rook but I found
this move Queen f6 and the main the main
problem with White's position of course
is their King is really exposed and
another small detail that's really
important is that the rook on a1 is
always hanging and without this hanging
rook none of this would be possible
because white would have stuff like
Knight takes e4 but here of course I
just take the rook with check and I went
back my material and and White's King is
still in huge danger and this happens
like this kind of thing just over and
over again because the knight on c3 just
can never contribute to the defense and
and why it is just in in huge trouble
here
so he played rook h2 trying to defend
King g1 was another option to get the
King away from the Queen but Knight take
C 2 is a good move and if Queen take c2
Queen takes c3 Knight takes e to I take
the rook on a1 so Bishop takes e2 is
forced and black just has a like as a
force check mate with the Queen and
Bishop
Queen g3 Knight takes e4 what move
should we play yeah just take it and
there's no background or anything
kingi to check in here I mean with the
King exposed like this it's not hard to
believe that blocks Queen and Bishop can
create some mating threats Bishop g4 and
check and when you back the peace I can
probably take on g4 right away maybe
this is even stronger and whites King is
just too weak maybe just um want to find
the most devastating victory here
they're just III yeah it's really bad
for white
so I didn't see that all the way until
checkmate because there was a lot of
moves but back here once I played my
takes f4 I pretty much saw that in all
these lines White's rook on a1 is
hanging so that prevents the c3 Knight
from ever contributing to the defense
and blacks queen gets into the game very
quickly and basically why it doesn't
have enough defensive resources so
Bishop g4 I took here
I mean f6 rook h2 and I took this pawn
finally so if Knight takes d5 Queen
takes a one with check and 93 Chuck is a
huge threat
so King g1 yeah I think I took on e too
yep so I finally wind back one piece and
the material count is a night and and
four pawns for a rook of course black is
completely winning here the pawns in the
center are strong like none of my pawns
are weak they're all very healthy my
King is perfectly safe White King is
still weak and and blacks even up in
material so look F 125 as you can
imagine we were both in a pretty serious
time trouble here so we didn't really
play the most accurate moves I don't
think black has to take this bishop but
I think practically it's a really good
decision just simplify because I'm up in
material now so I would love to just
have an endgame like Bishop and four
pawns against the rook because that
would be a very easy victory
but I just started pushing my central
pawns
you played aged six I just took what the
I should I just play two III the running
e to check I just took with this pawn
just to show my opponent like my bishop
is super strong and you know of course y
can resign here but we were low on time
so we kept playing some moves
d4 here it's I mean I could have just
played queen g4 check and like just gone
for checkmate like my king is you know
clearly perfectly safe
White's queen on its own can't do
anything just king g6 and there's no
checks and whites lost Richey to take on
v1 well you know I just I didn't even
want to allow one check like is I you
know of course I knew the game was like
really crazy and really cool so far to
like to spoil it you know by blundering
something would have been like crushing
like my world would be destroyed so I
just wanted to like play the safest
moves possible
gave some checks to make it to the time
control and then finally I force a queen
trade just because I just want to play
this end game where I have no losing
chances you know whatsoever but it's a
little embarrassing how long it took me
to convert this but we'll just look at
the end of the game brought my king in
and then I brought F pawn and my rook
comes in to h4 and h2 basically as long
as I don't blend into my ruck I should
win here and all I need to do is bring
my big my rook forward and have for now
I'm threatening eetu so I could just
play to immediately but I figured f3 is
even more crushing and here finally my
opponent resign so I hope that game was
interesting to you guys